you're not afraid to speak your mind
about your encounters with celebrities
that's something a lot of people really
like about you which it's not the
celebrities well here's the thing some
loathe you yes because they just don't
like you saying these things but others
eventually come around who's an example
of someone who came around and finally
said I'm okay with Kathy Griffin I'm so
glad you asked me that because it's
taken many many years and the new fun
[ __ ] Miley has finally come around
which is about Miley Cyrus when she was
Hannah from Montana right things were
shaking I'm not gonna lie but then when
she got the Susan Powter stop the
insanity haircut right I remember a
Susan Powter yeah no they didn't but I
got it yeah Susan Powter she's a woman
who was wronged by her man he cheated on
her she gained some weight so much he's
human and then she made a lot of tapes
and she got that she's not the insanity
yeah she was physical force but anyways
get back to my changed up her whole act
completely she's got the whole new
early-modern Miley and we were doing the
Rock the Vote campaign and it was very
cute because it was just the two of us
and I had kind of called her every name
in the book in my act at that point and
this happens a lot when I'm working with
people I just kind of play it by ear for
a minute and then finally she just turns
around she goes so like this whole time
when you've been making jokes about me
you're just kidding
I go yeah this whole time just kidding
just kidding
so you're just like trying to make
people laugh and stuff when you talk
about me I go that's all and then I
swear she goes okay we're two so
suddenly you guys were friends
that's that's nice she just she she came
around they don't always come around
what she did
you